this week on forward andrew yang gets
fired and is replaced by zach grauman
i've also got jules turpak here joining
me and we talk about the future of work
how gen z is looking at college
education and career opportunities
after college we also talk about how
will smith smack chris rock because of
course we're going to talk about that
this week on forward
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to long shot with your host
zach grauman andrew yang has been fired
and now i'm here
i feel like i owe him that because
he opened last thursday's episode with
the fact that i was fired with no
context just kind of moved on i'm here
with joe i'm here with jules turpak
is it turpak or turban damn it all right
no it's okay we can keep
jules turpak
the uh
who's been co-hosting with us um because
we're trying to expand what we're
offering expand our perspectives
yeah people in the comments were
confused they were like did that exactly
someone like had like a heartfelt
comment but i was like thank you for by
the way it was like three people it
wasn't a lot and i'm really grateful for
the three people that were at least
concerned not necessarily missing me but
concerned that i was fired uh without
without notice no i'm still here deal
with it um
guys good to be back what are we doing
today we're
we're going to talk about a couple
things but the biggest one
uh the biggest kind of overarching topic
on this is really the future of work
from the young person perspective
particularly boys i think but
there is a youtube generation there is a
gen z passion economy gig economy kind
of zeitgeist that is hitting young
people and
i'll say this from a personal
perspective
when i was in high school i was trying
to figure out
it was always college college college
but it still was like is this there's
still that back your mind was like oh
this is 250 000 a year for so many
schools is that worth it and now i think
the
the veil that the curtain's been ripped
away right and uh younger people are
questioning that every day so my first
jewels let's dive in uh i'd love to
i'd love to get your perspective on
let's start this just
when you were in high school or even
middle school like what what's the vibe
around college
um for your friends peers generation
that kind of thing well i mean we're not
like too far in age so i think it was
the same thing it's like college is the
obvious yes but um i mean with all the
bad that covert brought it
also exacerbated a lot in terms of the
education system and also future of work
i remember more so like
fast forwarding so like uh my first
internships and everything just like how
outdated the time constraints the
commute and everything felt just from
having to sit in this office whether i
get my work done
two hours earlier in the day or whether
i work better maybe at night i was like
these time constraints are very very
outdated
and
also just with the education system too
like
what is it i think it's
over 70 percent of college students
change their major at least once
like at least once
which is which is crazy you know that's
like a
it used to be like your lifelong career
choice and then it kind of just leads
into why i think it's like um
13
of uh
us adults are passionate about their
careers it just funnels right into that
as well so just knowing that yeah i
changed my major i believe twice and i
was like
and by the end of college um i felt like
i don't even like my major but no i'm
not going to change it a third time
because yeah yes sunk cost 100
so
it was crazy with the pandemic because
it exacerbated first of all work from
home which to be honest probably would
have been another five years until that
became normalized we accelerated a few
things yeah yeah i just remember
my corporate job
they weren't even touching work from
home i think the e-commerce department
at one point had one day work from home
they ended up taking it back because
they were just like
the ceo didn't like it and then yeah and
of course it exacerbated people feeling
comfortable taking gap years um which is
really really important so so there's
this narrative that um
our generation's been able to kind of
buck so like my parents generation my
grandparents generation
it was a
you know come back from world war ii we
win world war ii and it's like okay now
build the we've seen evil build the
country right and it was
less about
the individual more about the collective
good the collective whole and it was
um
if you got problems bottle them up
don't talk about them bury them deep
um
and
no one
cared really at least the sense i got
obviously wasn't there but that you know
if you didn't like your job or feel
fulfilled in your job you're happy to
have a job and contributing right and be
productive quote productive member of
society
and
that has changed
for a number of reasons one i think it's
wealth and prosperity and peace time
right like we really haven't
had any wars in the united states where
we needed to like really even raise
taxes for said war like the cost on the
american citizens for us going to war
has been essentially zero
um
and then
you then have social media and the rise
of the attention economy where it's um
more about more about me more about uh
my passion my love my
my personal brand and identity um but
what's
interesting is i didn't i grew up when
that was changing right i grew up like
aim
aol instant messenger was a thing in
middle school and then
texting started
um
and then smartphones became a thing when
i was like
midway through college and then that
kept going but there's kids where they
all they've known is the smartphone
right and just rapid technology and that
sort of thing so
have you
you know do you think there's a pressure
on you or your peers to find your
passion inspect instead of find
something you're good at or find
something that's quote productive
yeah well i think carly actually made a
tweet the other day i thought was really
interesting it's like uh
it's i'm not gonna word it right but it
was like she said uh
instead of follow your passion like
follow your curiosity is the best way to
go kind of what you're talking to like
yeah find things that make you curious
but you can actually be real really good
at because this passion economy is
interesting because you know we see a
lot of content creators and everything
um
blowing up more so from the creative
realm making videos and everything but
the passion economy also isn't all it's
made out to be like this weird thing of
having to monetize yeah all your hobbies
or everything like that and then do are
they really hobbies anymore when you
have to put all this time to them and
you're then entitled to obviously when
you're
connecting this to how you make money
with all these time constraints and it's
not so authentic anymore and it also
takes a lot of the fun out of it
probably a lot of your creativity out of
it because when you're pushed to such
strict time constraints that takes a lot
of creativity that's just not the nature
of actual creative work
but
i mean
just thinking about where we're headed
with the future of work and kind of
again back to college when you're
picking this one major and um
even just a generational difference i
think millennials are staying at jobs
average like max five years adults
before that were like 15 to 20. our
generation i assume is going to be like
a year per job and there's studies
though about um for gen alpha
specifically yes there is a generation
under gen z which is like the kids under
12 years older they're jet alpha which
is a pretty sick name that is a sick
name so gen alpha alpha because it's
like it's gen alpha but it's not like so
i jen and millennia are like a separate
from the alphabet
distinction so gen alpha's gonna
definitely stick there they might have
different nicknames jen alpha
yeah it's a pretty sick name but they're
predicted like aside from like your jobs
in high school and your jobs in college
in their actual adulthood careers are
predicted to have
um hold 17 different draw jobs across
five different industries
so that that's pretty crazy compared to
seventeen jobs five an inch as opposed
to
my dad
this guy would always pray for stability
like the same job same company just
wants a job and a paycheck and that and
it's just that is so different
than what you're talking about yeah and
across five different industries that's
huge in itself
it's just rapidly changing how we're
going to be going about work i saw an
nyu professor um
at one of our
i used to do these ubs client events we
bring in like these compelling speakers
and one guy came in and he said uh
the only skill set that matters is the
ability to learn new skills yes um
and if you're growing up in this you get
that um but is there
i i i'm questioning in the mixed
messaging particularly
i mean to both boys and girls i'm
assuming um
but
this scott galloway talks about it a lot
who i really like prof g and he said
it's the biggest little crap to be told
follow your passion follow your passion
because
um
and people are very successful like i
followed my passion just do you and it's
frustrating because if you're a
world-class artist and you're like
follow my passion just do you just let
your own self express out there you're
right if you're world class and you're
one of the best artists in the world
then yes follow that passion and be
completely unique because you can make a
lot of money off of probably correct one
and you know once a generational talent
and there's um there's other folks with
brilliant minds brilliant skill sets and
athletic abilities and things like that
whereas like follow sure follow that
great
but most of us aren't that yes um and so
following that passion may lead you to
frankly like trying to be elite at
something you're not a lead at and
probably
you know the the the adage is
don't do what um
don't have a career in something that a
billionaire would do for free or that
rich people do for free and is that like
it's why like
you know and like nothing against people
have done this so i love like starting
breweries or wineries or things like
that are
it's just a very very competitive space
because that's what richer wealthier
people do when they retire is they
create fun stuff like that um which is
not you know i'm not saying that's a
rule or that i stand by that but
it is
there's something about like the sex
appeal of careers or the passion that's
and has that been drilled into you was
like what is that how does that hit you
in high school nowadays or in college on
days and what kids are seeing yeah
before i forget too like to your point
yeah these out outliers outliers that
for example an artist like a crazy
once-in-a-generation artist yeah they
can take one painting and like make yeah
100k off of one painting and be kind of
set for the year while other people yeah
this is just their passion and they're
not that once right in a generation like
you are going to be probably having
these corporate clients or whatever
you're going to be stuck to these time
constraints and again like i was talking
about earlier it's not really going to
feel too passionate anymore anyway to
your point yeah i grew up watching a lot
of youtube like very much um throughout
high school and now it's more so for
kids youtube tick tock not so much even
instagram anymore right um
but yeah you're all over every day in
your face are these people who are just
making money off of the internet and
kind of their own personalities some
people have more like different
different niches in terms of maybe shock
factor content but a lot of these people
are you know lifestyle creators or
whatever it is and you're just seeing
them make a living off of being
themselves so um
that's what you're consuming all day and
when you're obviously whatever content
you're consuming is um
contributing to your world view so
that's in your face that's what you're
kind of aiming for
and then let me ask you this because one
thing i didn't have was when you were in
high school
or college do you have friends just
getting super rich off this stuff
or becoming
well even maybe it's not super rich but
it's super famous so there's tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
followers maybe you were one of them i
don't know when your tick tock blew up
but um
like did you did you have that with
friends does that i'm assuming that
changes the social dynamics so i feel
like i'm at the very oldest of gen z so
throughout high school people it was
still you just kind of followed your
friends on social media
towards the end you were kind of
following um people outside of that like
public figures during college you're
following public figures more and then
you're kind of seeing the rise of
content creators and influencers be
looked at as very serious figures and
they are become meshing with public
figures so right now though i notice
especially with tick tock for kids like
yes in your high school and within your
college there are people who
have a huge platform but that's so new
and like it's becoming normal that yeah
a bunch of your peers have these large
platforms because tick tock obviously um
for people who don't know it's the short
form video platform in it the virality
on there
you could have
you could have never had a viral video
in your life you could have zero
followers that one video just if it has
a lot of watch time can be pushed to
millions overnight it's a completely
different like
it's absolutely insane what this thing
can do yes
you know in the press they talk about
small businesses and how we have to
protect small businesses and it's
annoying because
nothing about
our business or most people who own a
small business nothing about that feels
small a small business can be millions
of dollars in revenue and when you're
running a small business time is money
which is why i want to talk to you guys
about stamps.com because stamps.com
saves us money all the time you don't
waste time with either repeated trips to
the post office or waiting in line or
skipping the nonsense it lets you print
official postage right from your
computer and saves you money in the
process so you can spend less time at
the post office and more time making
your customers happy which is why we
love it for more than 20 years
stamps.com has been indispensable for
over 1 million businesses like ours so
whether you're sending invoices or you
got a side hustle etsy shop or a
full-blown warehouse shipping out orders
stamps.com will make your life easier
you just go online print out your stamps
when you need to mail something and bang
you can take care of all your shipping
needs without having to go to the post
office so we want you to stop overpaying
for shipping with stamps.com sign up
with promo code yang for a special offer
that includes a four week trial free
postage and a digital scale with no long
term commitments or contracts so just go
to stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the page and enter code yang
check it out guys i think you'll like it
[Music]
so what is the
the internet right social media it's um
it's it's a version of the mob right but
it's a version of
this faceless
energy going towards um the mob doesn't
understand nuance things are black and
white there's good and evil right um
there's funny it's not funny there's the
um heroes and villains right
and
you end up in situations where most of
life is gray most of life requires
nuance
but if you are
quote wronged or feel like you are not
hurt or
upset with a situation or don't like
your boss or mad at your mom or you go
down whatever it is
you can throw it out to the mob at
essentially zero cost
and then what right and then
the person who is you know who has quote
wronged you has to now not only ideally
make it right to you but also has to
listen to the mob or ignore the deal
with let's call it deal with the mob um
kids know that nowadays and is that like
does that terrify your teacher did you
have teachers terrified of like
disciplining a child who had hundreds of
thousands of tick tock users for fear of
god knows what the wrath of the mob or
the wrath of
you know administration
well it's definitely weird now how
comfortable people are just recording
strangers you see all the time on tick
tock yeah whether it's at a concert and
you're like zooming in on someone
specific doing something like maybe a
little odd at a concert these videos
just go viral and i mean we've seen uh
you know kind of like the karen videos
go viral before like
you know that that whole stereotypical
thing that happened the past few years
but yeah now it's these uh videos of
strangers are just going viral and like
like you're saying people can
do a video on their teacher and get
millions of views overnight which is
definitely a scary thing because it
loses a lot of context and when you see
someone on your for you page you're so
um myself included everyone on tick tock
you're so used to in taking content from
strangers while on youtube you kind of
have your typical youtubers that you
tend to flock to or twitter you and
instagram you have your curated
following list on tick tock yeah you're
just in taking strangers all day you're
not really questioning what they're
saying at all so you're just taking that
face value you haven't checked it yeah
you have no nuance into their background
or like their motives
right yeah it's pretty insane so tristan
harris who is um
highly featured in the document
documentary on netflix the social
dilemma
um that dilemma is complicated but the
bigger one of the biggest things he said
is that it's both utopia and dystopia at
the same time yeah all of the good and
all of the bad equally um
and he's right in that when you're
talking about content and you talk about
web3 and you talk about um the potential
of this it's a it's like
it can't be more amazing right you're
talking about new types of currencies
and people making wealth of it and
having access to wealth generating
activities they never could have had
before you're talking about valuing
creator you get a list of all the
positive stuff
but the negative is really awful too and
it hits boys and girls in different ways
but also simultaneously i think
um
let's start with boys because you would
share an article with me from the wall
street journal that there's a generation
of american men that are giving up on
college um and it was 60 of
college students are women only 40 of
men
and that number used to be tr true the
opposite way um in the 80s or so
definitely in the 70s and 60s this has
been a trend like women have taken up uh
slightly more uh the percentage of like
the college student population since the
80s so it's always been true but it's
been exacerbating like crazy um over the
past 10 years specifically specifically
from 2010 yeah rapid rate it's been
going up so people have talked a lot
about the factors of this what do you
mean from your experience and let's
actually this it's i don't even
necessarily know i want your opinion but
i also want to know what your i'm
assuming your friends see this um
and it was talked about in college what
is like the general reason why
um at least why do kids think that i say
kids i don't know people
10 years younger than me well it's also
interesting because it's not just in
terms of boys um deciding not to go to
college as a whole it's even you see it
within the application process so you
see within the drop out rate of course
more men um men i think account for 70
of the growth and the dropout rate of
college but also you see in the
application process um that
uh boys men
at 18 i guess you're a man but um
not attending to their applications as
much when it comes to not sending in
their transcripts everything like that
they're like then kind of little details
um
boys men tend to be missing on which is
very interesting not as like i don't
know if detail orient is the word but
you're seeing a lack of motivation in
general just within that process even
the ones who are yeah putting the effort
forth to want to go to college
you're seeing that which is
very interesting you think so
there's a lot of studies on social media
making women
and young girls in particular suicidal
depressed anxious and all that but
besides the extreme
that we're talking about we're where we
have major mental health challenges um
to
we're talking about suicide rates
skyrocketing things like that besides
the extreme it doesn't seem to be
hurting women's
college application rates and that's
called female productivity at a young
age they're still let's call their
anxious stressed depressed but still
like still crushing it in a classroom
but boys seem not to have the same i'm
sure i mean the anxiety levels are
increasing for everybody but far less
than women
but it seems to be sucking some ambition
out
um
have you noticed that and i don't know
if you've um is that talked about
amongst your friends and
peers
so i i really just think this disconnect
with education at the end of the day we
see so um and i believe you and andrew
talked about it about so women
attempt to commit suicide more than men
but men follow through with it at a much
higher rate i think that just shows that
men i don't know the exact word but
they're just kind of more maybe intense
with their decisions so um we're even
seeing so i think all these problems
within within education of course funnel
into work you're seeing within the great
resignation women were actually leading
the way in terms of quitting jobs
but you're seeing yeah the dropout rate
and everything that's mostly led by men
um so there's definitely a correlation
there and i really just think there's a
complete disconnect right now between
yeah the education system and the future
of work um in terms of yeah you're kind
of picking one career choice for college
and kind of going full in that when in
reality the future of work is much like
when you were young and your your uh
job interest was changing often maybe at
one point i want to be a dolphin trainer
and at another point i want to be a
lawyer like um obviously
we hope our lawyers go to school for a
long amount of time like a few years but
yeah you're just seeing this come
complete disconnect between those two
and it's kind of
you're seeing it more so within the
education system boys are reacting to it
reacting to it but in the workforce
girls are reacting to it just as much
my doctor friends i have three or four
and most of them have fomo from
their friends that didn't go because if
you're a doctor
you're essentially in right like you
invest you decide when you're a
sophomore essentially in college and
then you're in for another eight years
plus a two you're finishing your
undergrad and then plus like another
eight years of residency in co so you're
you're in um and yeah as you should be
as a doctor i completely agree and i
have no shame but like they're they do
struggle with like my friends are
starting companies my friends or
um my friends are like oh you're my
friend's running for president i'm a
doctor like i could have yeah like they
feel confined in a lane in a way um
and
i'd say from my perspective as someone
who's done i've had probably
three different industries
uh three or four i've had careers in now
or whatever you've got whatever we call
a career at this point um i've done
activities in activities you end up also
frustrated too because you're uh more of
a jack of all trades and anytime you're
applying for a company or
building something you want someone with
a certain level level of expertise
and that's not always what you have if
you're doing lots of different things
lots of places yeah well to that point i
actually uh made a tick tock video that
kind of got a lot of reach a few months
ago about doctors and how i honestly
um i'm kind of worried about yeah our
generation in terms of we already are
going to make it through med school 100
no but like it's not funny no it's it's
not funny like and it's
it's a weird thing of like oh the people
can be like oh this is so sad i i agree
that of course we need doctors and we're
already seeing like um a disconnect in
terms of the supply of people in the
field
but at the end of the day it's like you
know i i've had some like weird health
problems and i remember the one time i
was uh
waiting for the doctor to come in and
the walls were kind of like
you could you could hear a decent amount
and he was talking to the girl next uh
well i don't know if it was a girl i
assumed it was girl um next door about
like her cancer diagnosis and then he
just comes over to me like in the next
room and you know it's all cheery i'm
like how does someone deal with that
emotionally on a daily basis you know
that as you like your full-time job not
that something like that should be fully
automated right um
but it's i don't necessarily like look
at it as like a negative obviously we
need people in that field for a wide
range of reasons um but i cannot totally
understand why there is a disconnect
it's a very mentally and physically
taxing job and um
yeah so i was talking about the worry
amongst our generation oh yeah it's
going to be able to go through that so
andrew when we were running for
president um he won the youth poll in
iowa um and actually most places um
for those that did pull their youths
and part of it was because he's super
authentic and there's a lot of distrust
in the system and he doesn't feel like
he's part of the system but there was
another piece of that
um because he was talking about a lot of
things that young people are
in some ways infuriated or scared by um
and automation is a big part of that
which is like this changing career
landscape
um
and
i'm gonna ask you like from a personal
level like when you
tell how did you pick where you went to
college and what you majored in
because now you are like probably by
definition
a jack-of-all-trades you can do a lot of
different things and yeah have like the
upside of doing a lot of different
things how did you decide yeah where you
wanted to go to school and what you
wanted to study yeah so i mean
i was a pretty average student school
was always typically hard for me because
i am more of i need like experiential
learning c's average or not like like uh
high b slow a's okay that's not average
by the way but i appreciate the harsh
criticism well amongst my school i felt
like it was on average i felt like i
felt like i was actually c was always
supposed to be average but yeah uh we
are the participation trophy generations
uh so i don't know i don't know if high
school still gives season i mean but i
always went like bare minimum in terms
of studying and everything like it was i
just it was a disconnect to me and my
interest in school so um but when i went
to college i initially went in as
marketing but everyone was like oh like
in terms of like my family was like
where are you undergrad um duquesne
university which is in pittsburgh it's
like it's where i got the most
scholarship money but it was a great
experience it's a highly suggest the um
but when you were deciding yes was it
yeah sorry so what what helped you i
mean so money is like the best thing
money is like a huge factor as a factor
for me too or you know something i
choose to ignore if i didn't want to um
was that the biggest factor or were
i mean marketing
oh well i changed my me you did change
your major but was it a factor on like
what i wanted to study or was it more
about money it was 100 about money i
changed to healthcare supply chain it
was literally just because my friend was
like oh um i know someone who majored in
supply chain and they made this much out
of the gate and i compared it to the
marketing like average salary out of
like once you're out
like that literally that's the only pay
of a average graduate
that was the the only thing that made me
change because you you graduated as a
healthcare supply supply chain
management which is crazy because
everyone was like what is supply chain
now everyone talks about supply chains
oh yeah well we have issues so did you
did you did you get a job in supply
chain healthcare supply chain i got a
job in supply chain out of college and
um my major is in college so my first
major was um within supply chain it was
just like a dust job my second um
uh
internship was actually do you know aldi
love aldi i could talk about that for an
hour straight like i am all for aldi fun
fact quick about aldi people like rat on
it as like a discount grocery store they
are just so smart so for example like
their chicken is tyson chicken they're
all they're like cereals are kellogg's
for example okay but they have a private
label so they're able to give it to
customers cheaper because if they have
this all d private label anyway i could
talk about i'll do forever german right
yes
um but um and they're very good at
supply chain i believe they're they're
awesome that supply chain but it was
like a district manager internship so
you were um i was shadowing a district
manager who's in charge of five
different stores and three weeks of like
my 12-week internship you had to act as
a store manager at one of the stores i
love these were you in pittsburgh when
you did it yes it was in pittsburgh and
this was summer of
junior year what was this yes summer
after junior summer afternoon and these
this these three weeks as a store
manager of one of the stores um yeah i
was doing the 5 a.m shifts getting up at
3 a.m and
during that time it's actually what
really funneled my interest into ubi
because i was just
first of all um andrew talking about
automation heavily and just
the first five hours of our morning from
like 5 a.m to 10 a.m we're just yeah
picking up all the produce putting it
down like these very robotic movements
not stimulating on the brain at all i'm
like you know this is the side of
automation that i can
get behind yeah i can get behind um and
obviously ubi is important in that but i
think if what really led me to ubi is
how it funnels into the future of work
[Music]
well it's interesting
so it's it's uh this is the challenge is
okay the job can be automated yep and
then the next question is should it be
automated yep and if you want to make
more money that answer is usually yes
but i think about um so my brother lives
in new jersey now just moved to new
jersey from manhattan
and
in new jersey you're not allowed to pump
your own gas
you have to
let someone pump it for you
yeah and it's a i mean straight up job
creation program by the state of new
jersey and wildly popular because
frankly it's a mild convenience
it's actually something and some days
it's a major convenience if it's cold or
raining there's someone
you legally cannot pump your own gas in
new jersey quick question i'm always
confused are you supposed to tip them oh
you're not allowed to tip them or you're
i mean you're allowed to but it's very
very frowned upon right because they get
paid decently well um
do you like this it's a good paying job
it's good wages i think i imagine decent
benefits because it's basically a
government jobs program
i have never been a huge fan of
government jobs programs i think it's
this is a good like private version of
it because the
the government says you have to
you have to have someone pump the gas
and you have to pay them i'm not sure
the actual legality of it but they have
to be paid a certain amount yeah um but
then the
gas stations themselves administer that
so it's not the government creating the
job itself it's they set the policy for
the private companies to create the job
gotcha um
look you can debate this back and forth
but the reality is it's employing a good
number of people and people need stuff
to do
um so that's like the hardest part right
like i'm totally big believer in like we
should automate automated automate but
then we gotta give people other things
to do exactly
uh anyway so
you go you work at all the you see this
firsthand
um
was the internship paid or was it like
college credit type deal it was paid
that's yeah aldi pays well another
another reason well it's hard because
it's they tell you to you got to get
experience but in order to get
experience you have to you know get
hired you have to have experience um oh
that's crazy i'll never forget all right
quick story i am my i went to uh i went
to duke university in north carolina by
the way final four
week
here we go let's go duke um
i usually piss off half the room you
know duke there's plenty of duke
people hey duke like i hate the patriots
i very much understand because i hate
patriots uh
but we don't cheat for the record um
okay
the
when i was um
a sophomore i dated a girl who was a
freshman and
she
her dad worked in finance got you and so
i remember i was a sophomore looking for
the big deal was like if you get a
sophomore internship because no one ever
hired freshman in college like that's
where you had to work big [ __ ] but if
you get sophomore internship is big
deals like goldman sachs had their
sophomore program no no and they were
like a couple banks at sophomore
programs most internships were for
juniors um juniors
you were you know you interviewed
throughout junior in the fall in the
spring and then you get your
summer internship
and somebody's internship paid like out
the ass like you're getting paid a
hundred grand for a summer and i was
like and what yeah like 70 to 100 000
like and live in new york i always think
and i'm like brother this is life
changing money for where i was coming
from um
watching anyone yeah that's pretty
life-changing so i was like trying to
get one of these jobs but if you get one
as a sophomore and then if you get one
at sophomore your game you're guaranteed
to get one as a junior because you have
something on your resume most people
have anything on their snowball effect
so i remember
like getting my girlfriend has helped me
with my resume
and
my resume was i was a lifeguard
for a summer every summer since i like
was 16 like i could in high school and i
worked at chili's
that was my resume and
i mean you know i had like i had a
resume to get into college whatever were
you at chili's were you like a bus boy
i love that job i mean i i can't say i
loved it but i agree restaurant jobs
everyone needs to have one at one point
oh yeah that's i learned a lot and like
it was um not great because the town
people i saw in town would come in and
see me there and like
really doing well zach huh like oh no
anyway so um
i was a host of chili's yep um
but uh
and her resume as a freshman was like
50x better than mine because when she
was a senior in high school she interned
at one of her dad's friends hedge fund
oh gosh and knew all the financial terms
and this sort of thing so she got one of
those sophomore internships so she got a
better internship as a sophomore
than i got uh or sorry better internship
for herself as a senior in high school
than i could get as a sophomore in
college yeah um and this is like the
kind of leg up stuff that i learned
pretty quickly um
and so how i got my experience this is
like the bs where i was a lifeguard at
the pool i was a pool manager but every
morning
i had
uh like a like a friend of a friend's
financial advisor like let me come in
and like literally stuff envelopes every
day and sit in like the financial office
of smith barney um did i learn some
stuff kind of but i got to put on my
resume like morgan stanley smith barney
wherever the heck they were that yeah
just the name and that helped me get my
foot in the door and it's
and i had to work i'd work for free
um
he was nice he gave me some cash under
the table not a ton but like he like but
like he legally couldn't pay me like
from there they wouldn't do intern so he
paid me like out of the kind of heart
just and it wasn't a ton but it was
enough to have some spending money
whatever but um that's the game right
and it's awful um and
wait clarify why couldn't they pay like
they just didn't pay interest so they i
mean they had like a formal internship
program but they did not have a budget
for like the
west hartford elmwood branch of
connecticut wherever it was yeah yeah
for their internship and by the way i
didn't deserve that money i felt like i
was getting
a charity handout because i did nothing
for him like i did give him your time
yeah i gave my time yes but i didn't
help i literally just got paid to learn
which is right and i wasn't there wasn't
like a full-time job opportunity there
in the short run
um so this is what's hard like um kids
need to get that experience but it's
investment of the company to to do that
um so
have your
this is actually where i'm going with
this
peers you know or the younger generation
let's call it gen z
uh as i catch all of like everybody
around this are they now focused instead
of like that like bs experience to put
on a resume are they more focused on i'd
rather be
a youtube content creator maybe get paid
a little bit that way or would i rather
be a
influencer or
get into web3 and make an nftr project
or something like that that's a little
lower upfront cost like what
have you seen
in terms of that experience check the
box thing from young people yeah i mean
i don't think it's
all or nothing towards either one so i
mean you're seeing with uh high
schoolers stay more extracurriculars
than ever before like in terms of they
need to like deck out yeah
deck out their applications and yeah
the burnout is crazy amongst young kids
in terms of what they're kind of
experiencing the pressures in order to
get into college which is
just crazy but i mean you're definitely
seeing in the back of everyone's minds
even those people with full-time jobs
today everyone at the end of the day i
don't think i think people
align gen z with a want for
entrepreneurship but at the end of the
day i think the reality is people just
want autonomy and not maybe to have
an entity over them 24 7.
so you're seeing like in the back of
people's minds yes when
you have every day in your face these
content creators and they have this
clear autonomy within their lifestyle
that's in the back of your mind and
you're maybe aspiring to that a little
bit in different ways but um i
i think more so you see this amongst
young boys and like their role models of
whether it's elon musk or whether it's
the garyvees and mr beast and the logan
paul's of the world um
you're kind of seeing them make harsher
decisions in regards to
yeah
dropping everything and trying to go
full into some to a decision like
content creation while girls usually
kind of
what i've seen are more so pursuing
those types of things on the side from
this is a really good point because
trying to think so i was growing growing
up
you know who your role who are my role
models right and i'm thinking like or
who are my friends role models right so
you have like
athletes you're celebrities and athletes
everybody right but then
for those in in some form of like
you know who are blessed enough to have
perspective on where they want to go
with their career what they want to do
then you start but it was
your steve jobs is your bill gates is
your it wasn't they weren't like
they weren't talking heads per se they
were just kind of figments and frankly
what they were like
obviously brilliant in um builders but
they were there was some form of
institutionalization around these names
yes um
and your warren buffett's your um
these types and
there was
or even like for me my this is like was
a very sad day when he ended up being a
pervert but uh matt lauer was a huge
like oh gosh i forgot about that
situation i i felt like i lost like a
i don't know that like a fatherly thing
yes like i really want to be matt lauer
growing up now i've learned that that
lifestyle is awful and like i've
lost my passion for wanting to be
hosting the today show four a.m mornings
yeah like oh man um
but
um but i mean matt or katie couric and
those al roker like they're creatures of
an institutional establishment of a
corporate america they had a clear
journey right and they clearly worked
their way up and those that was a thing
when i was growing up that was like you
could work your way up a certain way and
now
the role models for kids to your point
is that they're
they buck the trend
they if gary vaynerchuk gets aaron paul
where they're like uh they did something
crazy and then they built a platform out
of it and
the work your way up
uh abide your time
earn learn your skills earn your keep
your time will come mentality is now
make it now i'm famous instantly
uh you know and then you know
olivia rodriguez a high schooler writes
no don't get wrong she's a world-class
talent that's different but it's famous
now right
um
does that pressure hit
your generation and by the numbers it
seems to hit boys more than girls no
yeah well i mean olivia rodrigo that's
cut that stuff's always been prevalent
because that's just like child star she
was like
i mean she's a bad example yeah yeah he
is exceptional talent yeah but people so
for example yeah we were saying like
elon musk he more so falls into like the
steve jobs warren buffett and was yeah
within the systems and establishments
and
um obviously obviously he had success
young but still working within this yeah
he built his company from the ground up
and still does oh yeah
but um
so when we're seeing these other people
gary vee might not fully fall into this
because you know he does push i worked
like my ass off in my twenties and
didn't really see your internet
juxtapose you yeah maybe unfamiliar he's
a brilliant entrepreneur and
he was one of the pioneers of vlogging
wasn't he like video blogging like he
was a big social media dude yeah he was
he's the guy that holds himself he's
like we're gonna to the moon type uh am
i doing that right i don't know i don't
follow like carly loves
garyvee anyway but yeah i mean garyvee
definitely does push the messaging of
you kind of risk it all like you don't
really need to go to college exactly
which is of course funnels into a lot of
the mindsets of boys today but we see
with the mr beast and logan paul logan
paul had a situation where yeah he blew
up quick on vine so
went off with that but mr beast you even
see in his messaging that he's like you
know he just
i think he just stopped going to college
classes and just didn't tell his parents
and he was doing this entire youtube
thing he was every every dollar he made
off of his his youtube videos he was
putting back into future youtube videos
and again this guy's it's an out he's an
outlier which
there needs to be those and a lot of
people maybe embody like oh that that is
me next because what happens with these
content creators is it feels super
attainable like there are these averages
anybody can do it yeah these average
people
um and this happened to them because
risked it being relatable right that's
that's how they
get there
yeah and again the whole risk at all
thing uh you know stop going to school
and just put your all into this and see
you see success what's her name rachel
hollis um who's older um than the gen z
generation but she wrote the book girl
wash your face has been like an
influencer type but she's she said the
quiet part out loud which is probably
true is a lot of these influencers or
she said something like uh
basically went on a tire like i'm not
relatable like of course i'm not
relatable like and she's like i'm rich i
work my ass off like this sort of thing
and the reality is a lot of these like
people like look what she said was like
pissed a lot of people off i'm not
defending what she said but the reality
is like
to be this exceptional of a content
creator and this famous you usually have
to
you're probably working your ass off
behind the scenes and doing what you
treat like a media company like a
business like right um
yeah but a lot of people like oh i can
you know just pick up a camera and start
recording that's definitely happened a
lot on the girls side who do like
lifestyle content have blown up from
literally just like yeah recording their
days and such
but um you know in my experience and
i think that people you should always be
building on the side you should have
things that keep are keeping you stable
and have your foundation and then you
can risk it slowly and surely once you
have
like there's proof in the pudding that
for example mr beast was creating videos
since he was like in middle school or
something and there was proof that he
was getting traction and then he felt
confident enough
to go full into youtube a lot of these
kids are just like oh i can do it like i
feel in my soul that this is what i
meant for and they just completely quit
what they're doing and have no solid
foundation no proof of of like
yeah success one viral video today is
not proof of success like it was maybe
five to ten years ago when you can have
one viral video it really snowballs
today that it's it's becoming a norm for
everyone
probably has like one viral moment
online at this point not everyone but a
lot of people do or more for sure it's
more and more tough to monetize yeah and
even i noticed like you you know when i
meet people or something who follow me
it's like it feels more
friendly in the past it probably feels
more like oh like these people noticed
me from online it's just like your
digital presence is becoming like a
portfolio and you should treat it as a
resume to get you into your ideal spaces
and careers and not look at it as like a
means to an end let me put everything
into it like do it on the side build it
up and you will get into your ideal
spaces um
through considering it like almost like
a resume and a portfolio am i saying
this right or understanding you
correctly is
content creation should be a part of who
you are and what you do but not
necessarily your sole source of activity
and income yeah i mean
the average uh
lifespan or whatever of a content
creator online i think it's like
oh what is it
it's like two years or something like
that i might that checks out
yeah so you you see these people i'm i
mean and even people who are youtubers
um when i was young like i remember my
first favorite youtuber was fred like he
was just like crazy online he he's off
the map now in terms he makes youtube
videos differently now but it's
by no means what it was the attention
economy is hard to stay relevant you
need to be setting a foundation for
yourself and
um things that if it all goes away
tomorrow
it's fine because
you used it in a way to yeah
get you into other career paths and
build something for yourself outside of
it because also
people like to
dumb down what what it takes to be like
stay relevant on the internets like you
were saying there's a ton of hard work
that goes into it the attention economy
is hard and more and more people are
getting into it and um people are going
to find out quick even if they have a
good year
it can all go away the next year yes
it's hard yeah
[Music]
that's not a friend about this but one
of the challenges i think facebook has
dealt with
forever
in that
i mean they looked at it they created
this thing everybody wanted it at first
right um
and then it was okay well if we want to
keep this show going
we have to get people
to keep coming back which means
eventually we have to get them kind of
addicted to our [ __ ]
and it's just
billions of dollars poured into
contending in the attention economy
and eventually that will die out right
because our attention spans are only so
much they have to keep acquiring new
things or building completely new
products over time right yep that's a
hard business um
probably was easy for a while but it's
just gonna get harder and harder right
um
and that is
let me ask you is like
i'll preface it by saying this the best
advice i ever got was take every piece
of advice with a grain of salt i've had
great mentors give me awful advice smart
people i really respect give me complete
dog [ __ ] advice and i'm sure i've given
horrific advice to people too i'm sure
you have it's like advice of course it's
almost it's in the eye of the beholder
in a way um but what advice would you
have
with that background what advice would
you have
for for kids that are listening to this
in high school because we have plenty of
young followers and listeners how would
you approach college in a career because
like sadly like these decisions when
you're 16 affect you the rest of your
life um
they shouldn't and they're less
important now because there's so many
more opportunities and you have your own
everyone's got their own life trajectory
but advice you have or how would you
approach that decision today
i sound so like old saying this you're
old
so um on for high schoolers i honestly
advise like seriously like get a job
like it was like just a part-time job
even if it's three hours per week like
i in college i was so surprised how many
people i knew who had no part-time work
experience and then they get into
the current the current work system and
it's just like you're taken aback by it
because it really does not align with
the future work and there's kind of this
weird wishy-washy situation right now
and gen z is having a really tough time
in the workforce but what helped me um
also just
find out what i'm curious about is
having a wide range of part-time jobs
from high school and into college i i
worked in retail i was a gymnastics
coach i
yeah i work i did waitressing and
hosting and i worked at a gym like
having and and then all my internships
and supply chain and uh within grocery
like
all of these things they don't sound
like yeah sexy or ideal
but you take something and at the end of
the day experience is what's going to
teach you
what you're interested in and what
you're curious about and i
all my curiosity
fed from those experiences and funneled
into the type of content i wanted to
create and then on the side i started
using the internet as a portfolio
talking about my interest and everything
still having my full-time job and
everything i started using it as a
portfolio it complemented what i was
doing within work
and then that grew in itself on the side
and i was able to get even more ideal
experiences
through what i grew on the side and then
was able to fully go into there but it
was a strong foundation and i
really just
throwing yourself in a ton of
experiences it sucks that i mean
everyone kind of knows that high school
right now feels
the education system is pretty good in
terms of content up until
maybe sixth seventh grade and then it
gets to this point where
they're just kind of putting you in all
these classes of stuff that might not
even be beneficial to you in the long
run
it has nothing it's like when am i ever
going to use this if i want to be this
doesn't make sense but i have to take
this class
and
what's important is the experience like
i learned more in my internships and in
my in my jobs than honestly i did in
college i remember more from my
internships and jobs than all four years
of college like being honest like those
experiences are honestly priceless yep
um
i love that um
and i must have say advice i'd say cause
i hate when people like who are like
outliers have success and then they give
advice like just do what i did like
but there is some stuff that cuts
through
the first one is
i'll say i'll say three things one um
a lot of it's a big problem i've seen in
corporate america in particular is don't
confuse effort with results
there could be plenty of things that are
even profitable that aren't really
actually producing results your result
may be that profit but it can go away
pretty quickly and work is
the creation of value
it's supposed to be it should be one
plus one equals three um if you're a job
where it's just one plus one equals two
where you're
moving things around um and adding
layers to stuff the way tech and things
are going it's probably gonna get
automated or or they'll cut the
middlemen out soon so understand that
really understand what is the value
and being able to articulate that simply
um
two is
it sounds so lame but [ __ ] hustle and
um
mark cubies or what's a rich dad poor
dad actually is is the book um but he
said live like no one else so you can
live like no one else a lot of people
they want the yacht they want this um
but they don't
they're not willing to work like a
little bit and when you're young when
you're you know 16 to 35 or so in that
range gotta use that energy because
you're going to run out of energy i'm
34. i feel i'm like oh i'm like tired
when you talk to
people in their 50s and 60s they're like
i'm just weary um
and so when i was at ubs i was
i started this non-profit suit up that
was growing
and
the number one question i got from my
colleagues at ubs when i would tell them
about is like how do you find the time
for that
and that's what bothered me so much
because i was like all right we get out
of here at seven o'clock if you're an
all-star like working hard so i have a
couple hours before i go to bed so i do
work then and then
i work on one one or two weekend usually
one day during a weekend um it wasn't
like excessive even i was just i didn't
go to saturday brunch i didn't go to the
hampton shared house as often i couldn't
afford it anyway but to build what i you
know it was a non-profit too wasn't even
like a for-profit hustle but that opened
up to a whole bunch of new doors so i
got to learn new skills and that sort of
thing um
so
those are my big two um
what was my third one before i blank on
it
um
i don't remember i have another thing to
add go ahead i only had two i lied just
two so also i i think uh kids really
undervalue twitter so it's interesting
because when when i was um in middle
school in high school we were on twitter
a lot and then it kind of was weird
there was these two to three years
in reality twitter is very very big for
like yeah journalists
people in the political space people in
the tech and business space but outside
of that
kids like use it for stan culture pop
culture stuff but they're under
utilizing it when it comes to yeah
networking experience so i think twitter
is what linkedin wishes it would be
like linkedin is just terrible but um uh
so sorry sorry for link
there's like a lot of folks that are uh
really really trying to network you know
did your friends in college where it's
like i don't feel like you all are
friends i feel like you're a networking
club
and i i think um kids get the
misconception that um yes maybe a
following number when people go to your
page is uh kind of like a a sign of oh i
should take them seriously but in
reality the following number doesn't
matter that much utilize twitter and
like uh
when it comes to content creation let's
be honest not everyone has the the
creative abilities that will make them a
good content creator so
twitter's nice because you can cur uh
curate your curiosity so if there's a
study and you find it really interesting
like retweet that and like build up this
curation of like your curiosity on your
feed and literally like it is
you're
dming someone is at your fingertips now
i co-dm people all the time and they
often reply and it's just like then you
have this
it's just a snowball effect of
networking and i used to not really
understand when people were like oh your
network and is a huge deal it truly is
and
we we have an opportunity unlike ever
before where this is at your fingertips
right and it doesn't really yeah like
i'm saying it doesn't matter your
following number just uh build up your
twitter feed it becomes like a portfolio
for you with and it has little effort
because you can just be retweeting other
people's things and um also use it
authentically you see so many people use
threads and everything and it's like so
corny like so like you see you see
everyone do it it's just like just use
that platform authentically um i like i
keep saying in regards to your curiosity
code dm people and build that network
twitter's an amazing tool um to get you
opportunity but don't get addicted
because that [ __ ] is addicting
well but yeah i deleted the app i just
use the browser now your following list
is everything on there though like so
yeah you it's unlike tick-tock it's like
you can just unfollow people oh yeah
yeah um
it's just i find myself very addicted
and i follow empty like buffalo bills
twitter which i love there's so many
good buffalo bills content creators and
they i know everything about team it's
wonderful um it really i mean look it
fuels a fire of fan bases um it's crazy
the la actually i remember my third one
third piece of advice i have and this is
this is actually a take all by the grain
of salt but i think this one's very good
learn to public speak
take the time invest in yourself take a
course and learn how to speak in public
i need to do that there is no downside
to learning that skill here's a couple
of reasons
one you'll need it eventually at one
point another you'll always need it
whether you're because even if you're
like i'm an introvert i'm behind the
scenes
you'll need to sell something you're
talking straight to me
perfect here's the other thing
there's studies on this but anecdotally
it's brutally true
if you can speak articulate in public
and get a point where you can captivate
a room
they will think you're smarter and more
experienced there's just facts i did a
tweet rant about this but keep going uh
it's uh so i would say
um now don't get wrong public speaking
is hard most people feel fear public
speaking than they fear death so
if you're at a funeral this is a jerry
seinfeld quote if you're at a funeral
most people would rather be in the
casket than giving the eulogy if you
will yeah um
but um
but uh
seriously um that you can put that as
number one like learning bubble speak
will um
change your the trajectory of your
career uh there's a lot of people are
scott gallery's big on this but it's
it's massively true and there's oh by
the way these resources are available
they're not crazy expensive to learn to
take public speaking course and there's
tricks you can learn like oh i always
freeze up i always get so nervous first
of all everyone gets nervous when they
public speak the only way to not get
nervous is to practice so you have to do
it um
anyway big big believer yeah so that's a
hundred percent correct and in regards
to how nervous you probably speak
it's not that i'm nervous i'm very bad
as you guys can tell on here sometimes
vocalizing my thoughts so so no that's
like 100 correct for sure i have and
again this is an outlier situation of
like i've really appreciated elon musk
in the way that he is a terrible
public speaker but like but also amazing
because yes because yeah but he's
clearly taking courses on it and trying
to like learn and things like that yeah
but i've appreciated that that because
i i did a tweet thing about this the
other week i was like um
mannerisms tell a story in and of
themselves don't get me wrong but people
who are so fixed fixated on them to the
point where they can't appreciate the
value in someone's messaging are quite
shitty because like there are people who
are just like oh they use too many likes
and um so i can't take what they say
seriously but like also those types of
people often will
go and fall for something that a
well-spoken conor con artist pushes just
because they speak
fluent and that's yeah well that's the
heart so we learned this in the campaign
it was
andrew was under the impression that his
ideas would save the day they would cut
through right and he's like bernie never
combed his hair and like never worried
about that
and
he was wrong um he was right in the
beginning because and especially because
he would do podcasts and some
alternative media
and write in like the book
but when you got to the cnn town hall
when you got to the debate stage when
you got to the rallies you needed to
look apart and you needed and it's not
um
and bernie by the way he's put together
his hair is usually a mess but like the
hair is now a brand like andrew's hair
was not his brand
but it was um
there's a certain level of trust that
comes from
feeling like the messenger is
uh valid or validated or trustworthy
confident in their points yeah and
those little things can be distracting
for sure um
and it's all it's always hard to sell
people so when you give them more reason
to doubt you or think you're invalid or
things like that it's just um it adds to
it so we you know i gave him a fancy
haircut we put him in a better suit and
made all the difference
yeah yeah
but then you know and then by the way
it's like a look good feel good play
good thing which is uh
what's the name hope solo the goalkeeper
from the uh u.s soccer team
maybe he's
got some hot water but uh at some point
but i guess everybody has can we move on
but my point was uh she used to play she
was very vocal about playing in full
makeup
she was like look good feel good play
good like she'd go like cassandra like
to her but like dress the nines like i'm
ready to [ __ ] rock and i love that um
i would always for debates or if i had
to give speech at ubs had like my game
day suit you know game day jacket um it
i don't know whether that's helpful to
you or not but um there's something
about there's a there's there's a
certain value of the messenger versus
the message in in today's world too you
know yeah like whatever yeah you just
want to feel confident in the messaging
you're pushing so yeah whatever does
that um and trump was very good trump
like crushed this by the way like
uber competent all the time
direct like they like trump like you
could yeah if you could take away trump
the man and what you feel about him
politically and just look at him from a
pure marketing lens
he was remarkably consistent yep on that
it was always trump all the time you
know uh the the online version of
in terms of uh
writing content that kind of feels like
uh well spoken is kind of the blue check
mark on twitter oh yeah it's because
people sometimes when they see that like
oh i i should take what this person says
as you know fact or that it it's val
validating twitter as someone who is
blue checked
oh yeah i hope zach is blue check so
like but it's one of those things where
you also yeah be careful in terms of
just because someone's a good speaker
it's not me they're always talking so
we're more likely to get [ __ ] because
that i get dragged to twitter at this
point daily i think the by standards
like kids who are seeing like blue check
twitter like oh cause you you think of
twitter a lot of professionals is what i
don't know what kid's view of twitter is
yeah oh i'm thinking i think it's just a
i think in more media and a hot mess of
trolls yeah like the worlds were in we
see that but yeah a lot of kids are like
a lot of you know professionals who are
like uh well into their space and
everything so um
yeah take everything with a grain of
salt online in general
[Music]
so we can't end this episode without
asking you your thoughts on
um will smith smacking chris rock in the
oscars which happened
sunday night we're recording this on
tuesday
um
the internet was a fire um
[Music]
it was
you know what i'll say this and i
thought you had to quickly get your
thoughts is uh
very rarely does something just cut
through all of the noise and i mean all
of it right ukraine was close
i mean you know we're talking about like
breakthrough
the biggest one i remember
was tiger woods
oh gosh yeah and that happened over
thanksgiving so that cut through them
but everybody was together if you will
trump did a lot of that too when he
first started getting um popularity in
2015
but
will smith was like i had text from a
lot of people like did you see that
right so what did you what did you think
um
i don't know it's worth talking about no
it is and i think i actually have um
a bit of a different perspective on this
because i know it's annoying top and you
everyone has seen a million different
takes on this but i've watched um red
table talk which is jada pinkett smith's
show for the past i think they've had it
for like three years wow you're like a
fan here you know no i'm not a fan you
know but you're yeah you know what i do
yeah so i mean i haven't watched it in a
while but um i used to watch it a lot
the first year it was out okay and so
you know like i i have my thoughts about
her and they're
more more so sway positive but um yeah i
mean i have a lot of respect for their
family unit and i think people can you
know say what they want about the the
internal workings of their relationships
but also like how hard it is to stay
together in hollywood how many divorces
and everything you see like you know
relationships are going to have their
ups and downs whatever so yeah i think
when people go that route it's kind of
um just weak a weak argument but um
in regards to over the past two years
you've seen that family try to be like
teared apart by the internet
trending
often like there was like three
different instances and i they were all
kind of for similar reasons but a little
bit different and just people ripping
them apart like so
you got young kids too and it was
probably their first ex they were always
very like positive in the limelight yeah
and so like that was probably their
first experience of that and it was
crazy how hard people went at them and
so i think that over the past two years
they're probably just fed up with the
public exhausted i think it was a lo the
situation was a ton of build up and
um and yes she's been dealing with her
health issues and that she's been very
vocal about in terms of her struggles
with them so like i
the chris rock joke to me i i didn't
think it was like that crazy it was
disrespectful for sure um i did think
that
like there's no reason to go to physical
violence though i will say
it was people are running with the word
punch and everything it was a [ __ ] slap
you do that with your siblings i mean at
least i did with mine sometimes it was
like he walked away right after he
wasn't slapped though it looked like his
face was swollen up as he was
trying i mean
good for chris rock yeah it was it's not
uh
like you should never boil it down to a
win-win or lose-lose situation there
there's none of that here i mean chris
rock took it like a champ i get will
smith's personal build-up though i think
it was stupid
um
but i i don't like i don't know it seems
like in the long run it's just going to
be whatever
so actually this is a good probably it's
a great job look the event happened in
israel is the memes are hilarious um
i tweeted this and i i stand by this
like we it it does show
that we can all look at the exact same
thing and have completely different
takeaways um and even find ways to get
invites over them um which is state of
the country
i will say this and this is why i'm i'm
curious i'm fascinated by like the
dialogue around it because
words matter yes
but they don't matter as much as actions
and i think that's the nuance i think a
lot of people
like words matter words or violence and
like
we say that because donald trump would
throw words around all the time and that
was like the epitome of like okay come
on what are you saying and
the things he would say or allude to and
wink wink at and things like that were
awful um
but also actual violence is actual
violence right um and so there's a
difference between a joke and
slapping someone and hitting someone
right those are different and one is
worse than the other if you physically
hurt somebody that is worse than
emotionally hurting somebody generally
speaking there are probably fringe cases
of
a pinch versus
emotional torture right we can go to but
like if we're taught in general you
actual violence is actual violence
and i don't i think people really
disagree with what i just said i think a
lot of people
probably on the left more often think
that words are violence um
and i
maybe i don't know if your thoughts on
that um just where we are as a country
or we believe that and i thought the
ukraine would kind of open our way
andrew and i had an episode on this and
talking about what pure evil is
um i don't know if we're gonna get there
i think a lot of folks are very scarred
by words that are said to them and it
feels like actual violence and i i don't
know how to i don't know if that means
meaning that toughen up like that's
probably the wrong phrase but
um
it was a stark difference to me i don't
know if you agree or had thoughts on
that
yeah i think if it like you're looking
at it just like at face value i
completely agree with that i think maybe
people's perspective um
there just seemed to be so much nuance
in this situation like i don't know
chris rock and will smith's relationship
or anything but like yeah at the end of
the day it's like
an open hand slap too it's kind of like
a a disrespect of like you're not even
worth a punch type of thing
do you know what i'm saying i don't know
maybe no i don't know
like i just didn't i know like i i hyper
analyze stuff too much but i don't know
like i
was just like uh open him slap like dude
what are you doing and then walk away i
will say my friend went to my friend was
in production when we were
in an internship i was living in la for
an internship uh in restaurant
management and he was working for
the show so you think he can dance um
and he was like a producer uh and but he
got to go i think to the emmys or one of
these award shows and he was telling me
like
because they're like at a feature table
it's like he's like i'm like he's like a
kid you're not
everybody's hammered
everybody like blackout like everybody's
wasted now i think the oscars are
slightly different
but i i'm assuming people i don't know
if will's drunk it doesn't matter she's
a high emotion but i don't know i don't
know if he drinks i don't think he does
actually um so like i will say
um
i would be shocked if people around them
weren't hammered because that's kind of
how these uh award shows go
so
um
i try that now there's like maybe that
hyper analyze it yeah yeah yeah i'm
trying to hyperventilate the reaction
because that's where we are but um yes
yes
uh
but yeah
yeah if you probably google like you
know drunk oscar moments there's
probably plenty um anyway
this conversation got a whole bunch of
ways but i hope you all enjoyed it any
closing thoughts jules
um
yeah i think we just need to
speed up the education system in regards
to yo how we just need to do a whole
reassessment um in terms of
experiential learning rather than uh you
know this textbook learning um how kids
are consuming learning materials are
essentially content and how
uh kids are consuming content online and
what is compelling to them it's not
translating into the classroom and
there's just a whole uprising that and i
don't think it's that difficult it's
more so just
utilizing youth voices as a way to
really align on best next steps um and
also not putting people behind because
right now college is just not aligned
with uh what work what what work is
gonna be like in the next five to ten
years
and for the college system to still
thrive it needs to catch up as well one
of the things i'd like to do in the next
episode is dive into what
how to evaluate the is college right for
me how do i cost benefit this out
personally i took a ton of debt yep and
i thought my school was worth it but i
don't
know if i would say the same today and i
don't know
if it was a different school
that calculus changes right
so
more to come
jules great to have you thank you folks
we'll see you next week andrew's back on
monday and then we're back thursday
enjoy your week y'all
[Music]
you